back to school time is exciting and
expensive we checked in with the clark
county credit union the sponsors of this
next segment
about their back-to-school budgeting
tips
creston welcome back thank you rocky
it's so great to be here
great to see you and great to talk about
families budgeting school supplies and
budgeting going back to school after a
long time of distance and at home
learning so
let's talk about it okay that's great um
back to school season is the second most
expensive time of the year
right behind holiday shopping so
families do need to be prepared
this year it's going to be a little bit
different the in classroom
sharing of supplies is going to be
discouraged so
the kids are going to need their own set
of supplies this year and with expenses
being higher than ever before
you know before the pandemic how can
parents prepare for back-to-school
shopping
that's a great question rocky first of
all i suggest
go through your house see what items you
have maybe you had bought some things
that didn't get used or didn't
get worn out and could be reused again
maybe you have an extra box or two of
tissue that you can throw in the supply
the supply box um get with some families
in your neighborhood
and maybe assign different bulk items
for people to get
and then just kind of share those those
are just a few ideas that maybe could
save some families a little bit of money
that is great i advise great tips i mean
what does cccu
do for the community um in terms of
back-to-school shopping how are you guys
helping
every one of our six branches has a bin
that the public can bring in supplies
they can drop them off
um we also have our service department
over the phone
you could call in and make a donation if
you are a clark county credit union
member you could call up have money
transferred your account make a donation
that way
we're taking monetary or supply
donations in the branches
so that's that's great and if people
want to help you guys donate supplies
what do they need to shop for what do
kids need
well the lists are out at the school so
the parents could get the list from the
school but the public if they want to
donate they're looking for copy paper
they're looking for
lined notebook paper pins pencils
crayons
the usual hand sanitizer is going to be
a big thing masks are going to be a big
thing this year
we also there's a lot more chromebook
usage so they're going to need some
headphones
we um donate to some of the lower income
and high population homeless youth
elementary schools
so we're also asking if anybody could
donate some
unused socks underwear possibly some
lightly used jackets for the fall when
it starts getting cold these children
will need as much as they can get oh
cousin thank you so much i understand
why this is one of your favorite times
of the year
and i'm glad that we can welcome it back
thank you i am too
thank you to clark county credit union
for sponsoring this segment give them a
call at 702-228-2228
for more information that's our also
where you will find bonsai their
financial literacy tool that offers a
free budgeting calculator